- Your accent reminds me of home.
I always love when I run into you.
It just feels, so where did you grow up?
- I grew up in North Carolina.
- North Carolina?
- My mom made be a debutante, that's how
Southern I am.
- You're a Southern belle.
- I am.
Wait, what did that entail,
what did you have to do?
Oh, my gosh!
- Ooh!
- I was like, "What happened!"
(all laughing)
- You are so fancy right now!
- [Fortune] Y'all, I had to wear
a white wedding gown.
- Oh my God,
you are from like the bricks,
I was from the sticks, girl.
We didn't have anything like that.
- Listen, but we had no
money, that was the thing.
My mom had been one and
then we lost all our money.
(Kelly laughs)
It happens.
- It happens.
- You know, gambling.
(all laughing)
And then she still wanted me
to carry on this tradition of being,
pretending to be rich and
then go to etiquette classes.
- That's amazing.
- Etiquette classes?
- Yeah, I had to learn how to be a lady.
(all laughing)
'Cause, no, I didn't know, I didn't know.
- I don't.
- I had to like,
dab my face with a napkin and, you know,
you can't wipe your face like a monster!
(all laughing)
- Obviously I didn't attend
etiquette class (laughs).
- Well, I still to this
day, people are like,
"You should never eat in public,
"'cause it's not great."
(all laughing)
- So what did your family think
whenever you told them you were gay?
'Cause, being from the South,
that is not always an easy conversation.
- Yeah, I mean, I think my mom,
for her, she didn't want
my life to be harder than
what life can be, you know?
- Already?
- Already, but we had this
really poignant moment,
I talk about it in my special,
where I told her I was gay
and she was like stone-faced.
And I was like, "Oh, man,
does she hate me now?"
And she was like, "We
are goin' to Hooters."
(all laughing)
- I what's like, "What?"
- What?
- So that was her way
of being like, "I accept
you, let's go to Hooters."
(all laughing)
And then when I told my dad, he was like,
you know, he's a very typical Southern man
that's very simple, and he's like,
"Okay, all right, well, do you want us
"to buy you a men's blazer?
(all laughing)
"Or a top hat?"
What?
Lesbians don't wear top hats.
- I love it, but in his mind,
if women like men, then
you wanna dress like a man.
- Sure, he's like, "Okay, let's get you
that top hat and blazer."
(all laughing)